the thing is that obviously politicians
don't like to give out their power I
need to know all the politicians also
the private sector the companies that
are already there they don't like their
interest to be to be played with but in
whatever I would have a clear example
that freedom works
well basically the numbers let's say
1995 were that we had a country of
almost 11 million people where we had
two hundred and eighty nine thousand
telephone lines throughout the country
what L was a state-owned monopoly which
was in charge of telecommunications
within what L there were five unions
which basically control the company and
you had a lot of corruption throughout
throughout the company because of the
nature of the monopoly and the nature of
the unions and all that so you had a
country with no phones if you want a
telephone line you had to pay someone
you know five thousand or ten thousand
catalyst as a commission so you can get
a telephone line and sometimes you paid
that and the telephone line was not
installed so basically that there was
the the environment that we were living
in well in 1995 we had national
elections and alvaro our sue was elected
president he appointed me to go to what
L as a set of Waddell and he told me a
very simple phrase he said I want a lot
of phones everywhere fast in the past
every time that something was being done
to sell what L or the electric company
or whatever the unions just got out to
the street on on strike and they stopped
the country so a law was passed in
Congress that the unions that belong to
public utilities for public services
they cannot go right away on strike they
must follow a legal process to go on
strike
and if they do it just right away they
could go to jail so basically that put
the handbrake on on the unions on
whatever they wanted to do and it gave
us the space and the time to work with
them to explain to them what was going
to happen and and basically we achieved
that with our unions we had a great
great relations with the unions at that
time we said okay we need to install 1
million lines okay let's see if a
state-owned monopoly can do it the
investment that we should do for those
million lines throughout the country is
over 1.5 billion dollars are we going to
be able to achieve that as a state-owned
company no we will go to Congress to ask
for the money and Congress will not give
it to us because there are other
priorities okay so we cannot do that an
important thing to mention is that at
that time their recipe that the World
Bank and the International Monetary Fund
and all these institutions were telling
our country say was you must sell a
monopoly that's the way to do it and if
you sold a monopoly do you set up goals
for the monopoly to the private monopoly
now to achieve and you must regulate
them to make sure they achieve your
goals okay what happens if we sell the
monopoly like Peru did like Chile Mexico
Venezuela Panama all these countries
were doing that let's see the results
let's see their performance and when you
look at the performance they they had
not installed new telephone lines at the
rate we we need it okay so if we want 1
million lines everywhere right away why
don't we let whoever wants to come in to
come in and do it we set a plan divided
into phases the first one was we were
going to open the market to full
competition
without privileges for everyone or for
anyone because when when you talk about
opening to competition then the entrance
they want to have privileges against the
incumbent and that's not there and then
you have the incumbent saying you cannot
let anybody just come in right at me you
have to protect me so we said we will
not get into that discussion we will
open to full competition day one that's
the way we're going to make the
difference between the boys and the men
and then we set up another team that
worked on how were we going to do to
sell the telecommunications company
because it had no sense if you have a
market open to full competition to have
a state-owned run company today they're
gonna kill it obviously the guys from
the World Bank and all these
institutions didn't like it I mean we
had rough discussions when they say what
you're doing is wrong but we had to tell
and listen but we're not asking for
money from you guys so we're just
telling you what we will do but we had
at that time was political opposition
but because the people out there there
were no phones so they were expecting
phones and the union's they were they
were with us and obviously a political
opposition they were against us for
example in my case I had to face over 40
lawsuits throughout eight years for all
the steps and all the actions we had
taken to open the market and sell the
company well right now we have like 13
and a half million people in it so out
of the country
in the metro area we have around 3
million people but we're 13 and a half
million people in the country we have
over 18 million telephone lines mobile
and fixed we have different private
operators here getting a telephone line
a cellular operator is as easy as going
and buy a hot dog industry like in
Guatemala you have a me
telecommunication service with the same
quality or maybe even better than the
ones you can get in New York in Tokyo in
Paris in London we have exactly the same
quality in that sense in
telecommunications we are not a third
world country we are a first world
country the peasants
throughout the rural areas in Guatemala
they have a telephone line so they can
call a doctor if someone's sick they can
call and check the price of their
products to see what they are offering
them at that moment it's a per price or
not I would say that the transformation
that we have achieved from 1998 to this
date it's it's amazing
you